great for those who are joining this
livestream this is a continuation of our
discussion about machine learning
functions fourth language and etienne
here is sharing and let's get started
well we got through last time so last
time so we we cannot finish talking
about learn distribution and then we
talked about anime detection right we
started talking about whether we wanted
an anomaly detect function or whether it
should be an anomaly detection function
yep I think for now we still on a new
addiction side with a bunch of
pre-trained anomaly detectors yes
yes they we trained we spent some time
discussing about this p-value thing yes
and in the end were all happy with
anomaly detection threshold which leads
to off of the question of how do we call
when we query is property for give an
example which you know in the past would
be among the p-value but now we're not
talking about p-value threshold but more
anime detection threshold what but what
we discussed last time is that this
thing isn't really a p-value is that
true it is it is an extension a p-value
I don't think what do you mean an
extension is it is it well interval and
then you know like I mean actually in
your word the p-value is a probability
to have an event that is rarer than the
current event so you know in that sense
it is a p-value although you know the
definitions are not I mean I guess to
make clear it could be the PDF p-value
look all this precision I mean these
distributions are very floppy objects
this is hardly you know given pictures
of cats and dogs we are hardly
reproducing you know this is the perfect
Gaussian distribution of it all well
making sense
I mean this is just some number
basically true
I mean it's according to this
distribution what is it probably to have
something more extreme
meaning less likely in terms of PDF but
but I agreed it might be and you know
there's p-value in other place in the
system I think might be confusing I'm
working a to call it p-value okay but
the previous thing that we had was
anomaly detection threshold which is a
number that gives us at what value
between 0 and 1 we consider this to be
an anomaly is that correct
exactly exactly
which by the way we decided for
analytics and threshold because to be
likely that in some future you would
give that directly to class you get to
classify because the classifier might
have an anomaly detector which when
triggered you know I agree that anomaly
identification threshold or just anomaly
threshold not just a nobody threshold
yeah one thing though that I should
mention right now because ok this calls
for you know going away from the p-value
but there's a there's a part where we
might want to go back to p-value in the
case of denoising so we've been thinking
of using line distribution to do
denoising data analyzing function in
some sense so I mean the the names are
completely open and we just which is
which is something I mean some college
you know denoising some error correction
basically the idea is to learn you know
the distribution when you have data that
is not noisy and and then you use that
to kind of correct the data
attitudinizor data and the idea is to
climb the peak so really I mean unless
we really want to be more modest wasn't
is can it not be called D noise
I see it stated he noise because D noise
might be more like audio or something
but it probably could be used for do
defeat Li definitely actually we might
have some that any new thing for you no
no what about what about just D noise
the function D noise because this would
act directly on the data like following
the same design of learning function
with a verb act directly from the data
and the whatever that is reads why do we
have the word data in front of it I
wanted to make it less yes let's
I mean it could be also unsupervised you
know anything I don't know well yeah
that would be what denoise of data would
do I mean it's an effect unsupervised in
the sense that it is trying to I mean
it's in the family of classify predict D
noise I mean what's wrong with that yeah
I mean why not one thing is that yeah
it's unsupervised so it doesn't assume
anything about the noise
it's just I'm learning about what normal
letter is I get a new example I make it
more no more yes so we could imagine d
noise of data it's going to assume what
type of data that is and then use its
standard denoising function yes option D
noise is a denoising function
I see yes to already know is yes yes yes
there could be some sort of yeah
although maybe that's maybe that yeah if
you have it you won't yeah sorry I take
that back it should be D noise of the
function comma data just like it's D
noise of I mean just like it's
classified of the function commentator
yes by the way it's not entirely clear
how we would act on for example for this
one
do you know is data in such clear either
how we would do because again we need
twelve distribution on the normal data
but we have the noise data so as some
sort of bootstrapping that must happen
there which is a bit similar to what we
do in anime detection and images we have
look we we have a bunch of sort of
ordinary images of the world so if the
noising is you know I don't know photon
shot noise or something in the image we
probably have a clear idea what
denoising would be yeah if the noise is
somebody photobombed my image then
obviously we have no idea what the noise
is there yes yes I mean just just remain
where this function is the idea we to
learn you know from the data and then
use it on the data I understand but
there's also a pre learnt D noise that
would be just learned on all of the
images we've seen yeah yeah yeah
something like similar to the beam team
that we've talked about before right as
a practical matter you know
if we have
right so the question is that I didn't
know the function is a function and you
know the functional function and I guess
in a similar instead of you know the
email it will be more dinner as a
function of image they will evaluate to
another function why I think it would
just be denoising of image evaluates to
the denoising of image evaluates to a
denoise a function when the other way
full and distribution we thought it
should be you know learned distribution
of the image that would evaluates to but
I guess both both will work for sure
but you know what Mike
yeah I see I'm not just certain okay can
we go back to look at anomalies again
yeah but just to know we will likely you
know give the users a possibility to set
to which until you know when we should
stop climbing the PDF like you claim you
climb you climb and when you it is
similar to anomaly it's like kind of one
sort of anomaly anymore we figure out
that well there's no noisy aminos
there's no error in the data anymore so
so we might we use these threshold you
know I understand you say that that's
why I wanted to bring it up now you make
the shown as well okay yeah like this
would be in practice the same thing but
different names but actually not
threshold it's the wrong way around
denoising limit
or denoising it's something like that
I'm not certainly noising limit it's
right but it isn't a threshold because
the other way around is above this is
where as this is saying below this
what's it do you know using bound upper
bound bound bound bound it's better than
limit actually they're both no way do we
know the animation is below that you say
it's an anomaly upper bound for the
noise for the noises that you cannot go
you should not go more than that above
that you can sit above that so your
point is that that in both yep yeah you
consider it a noise or an anomaly below
that value exactly is that I don't think
it's a threshold in either case mmm let
me think what are the functions to be
have we must have a bunch of image
processing functions that have
comparable things yes yes yes yes let's
see we see if we could find shadi for a
minute she would know all about this
stuff in there so in paint is for
and that for noise before Christmas in
values and it's lovely another ones look
at the options for in paint up there up
up up up up up up up in the details an
option yep yep my situations method okay
okay let's wait for shorty and that's
okay let's keep going with other pieces
of this design okay so yeah so there is
this value again I mean this is property
that we should climb name yeah yeah yeah
I understand but but let's just
understand what anomaly detector can you
scroll up a bit so the workflow is you
start off with okay so
functions like delete anomalies yeah do
we really want delete anomalies or do we
want to do something with the anomalies
like smooth them out and so on this
would be denoising you know thing is
kind of taking an already and making
non-anomalous
what you mean yeah it is well I mean hmm
well so what does delete anomalies mean
it means if you've got a discreet list
simply remove the elements which are
anomalous is that correct yeah
okay
okay so deletes anomalies it's fine okay
so what is what is some not sure if you
heard or shy here okay great um we are
trying to name an option for this
threshold for essentially a p-value
threshold which isn't really
convincingly a p-value for a bunch of
these functions and we want to know what
image processing functions have similar
options okay
what kind of flush all the options do
you have do you have something which has
a straight option called threshold I
don't think so threshold is a function
there's no no okay don't fire there is a
recognition threshold you could release
them right we have more specific option
names like main color distance and so
forth yeah okay what we're trying to
name here is but okay I want to go back
okay
delete anomalies takes a list of data
and deletes those elements which are
anomalous in it correct yep okay that
one is fine okay let's go keep going
here so classify takes something which
is considered an anomaly and essentially
that's the indeterminate threshold thing
right which is it says things that are
below the anomaly detection threshold
yeah except that currently an tamiya
threshold is specifically look at the
probability of the classifier so it's
not really normally detect Oh is just
like is it an option for classified yes
yes yes yes so it's it's it's different
n-terminus threshold is we are not sure
what it is but we still I mean it might
still be one of
possible class the anomaly's threshold
will be we know it's not I mean we
believe it's not part of any class that
we have okay so but it's got to be named
something similar to indeterminate
threshold because that's basically yes
I mean alternatively we could even have
a list here I don't even know how we
want to do this I mean so in other words
basically what's gonna happen and we
probably want an automatic setting for
this thing right because what you're
saying is so what is this going to
actually return it's going to return
indeterminate there that's weird
as opposed to what does it return if
it's not part of any class
sorry I mean classify returns a class so
well okay the class determinate right or
indeterminate or what is it dutifully
anomaly if he thinks it's an anomaly
well we thought that it could be a
missing not recognized mm-hmm
actually which should be different
because you could not recognize but
still think it's part of you know it's
like oh I lazy to care of a dog but I'm
pretty sure it's either a cat or a dog
exactly which is what I supposed
indeterminate threshold was supposed to
be yes exactly but is not clear in that
respect right so it would be you know
it's like out of distribution and I'd
think I mean of course not this but yeah
it's kind of this type of things we want
you to say well it's look it's almost
like it valid invalid input you know I
mean unfamiliar input I don't know
unexpected input yeah but it's not quite
that's not quite right out there I mean
neither of those is very clear so so not
recognized means we think it's part of
the distribution but we don't know which
part and why would we ever get to that
with if you have two things that are
very close to each other let's say Oh me
no I mean well not resolved would be a
better thing than not recognized then
not recognized sounds much more like the
if that's the case if it not resolved
would mean the thing where it's one of
them but we don't know which one and not
recognized would be we don't think at
any of them not result we have to know
that this thing might be used for all
sort of predictions so like predicts
that can print a numerical value oh so
what will mean other thing when does it
I mean so you're saying we don't know
what the numerical value is yeah we're
not certain enough to show a result
that's kind of uncertain missing
uncertain
you
as opposed to missing not recognized I
think that's nice very clear
yeah well okay uncertain is okay but not
recognized meaning it's crazy basically
[Music]
see we don't explain why I mean
but then DUI specified threshold for
being certain or completely crazy or
being uncertain see enormous input is
pretty weird when you type in I mean
it's it's very pompous in a sense if you
type in some random gibberish and it
says anomalous input then it just means
I don't know what language this is in I
mean it's kind of a none of the above
it's probably
name for this thing out of this
tribution
[Music]
you
thing to remember is when people talk
about for us I mean it's all out liar
I think there's a name like like adrift
something drift well I think 36 there's
a name for that when you'll test data
you know drifted is significantly from
the input from the training data boy
it's not slide on them but it is for
sale anyway never mind
let's see okay back to this
that's a good name concept drift in
pretty analytic machine learning the
concept brief meanness ethical property
of the target variable which the model
is trying to predict changeable these
are the targets viable like is the class
prior changes for example alright okay
so look we've got that the basic bottom
line here is we've got two cases can we
just write out the two cases that we've
got
you know missing uncertain
and we've got it really isn't any of
these
right
yeah yeah it's in the set but okay so
that one there is it is one of the set
but we don't know which and then the
other is it's really not in the set
you
[Music]
listen I mean if it was classify it
might be set like missing no
identification of something
yeah it's because
input is no matter I think it's also
good too because you know they say
something about the input I mean I don't
know okay but that's okay they don't
know much missing I'm it sort of out of
range
but that's not um just missing anyway
well adjectives probably look gibberish
is not an outlier
um
out of band out of that's that's some I
don't think you know learn nothing from
this I think there's another one
this concept written that is
know some concepts this is start gonna
be it's gonna be some statistics
challenge nobody else understand so I
just don't think missing okay look we've
got the concept here so let's get that
stupid thing off the screen distribution
I think it's very hard to understand if
you just shown that by the way we've got
a bunch of background noise if we could
stop that would be great let
missing
well not recognized as the other see the
problem of that is unrecognizable
I mean okay write down unrecognizable
uncertain and unrecognizable
do you understand yeah yeah yeah okay
I think that's not absolutely terrible
uncertain unrecognizable yeah although I
think in the work name you should refers
to whatever sorry
why was that to classify you know this
option we put the threshold option like
like you know if you call it an already
threshold then it would make sense to
return a normally them and it knows oh
this is it exactly he's an organizer
ball then the user says they don't know
that they can change anybody threshold
too you know because you see what I mean
what do we have we had another thing
called recognition threshold didn't we
did you go back to the documentation on
the right yeah location threshold yep
it's probably missing out not
unorganized and notified it will be nice
if you know that seems like it's the
same concept of this recognition
threshold doesn't it
this one is not about the anomalies of
input it's about I understand it's about
whether we consider it to be an adequate
recognition which is very similar to the
question of whether they also return the
same am but okay so that one missing
unidentified I mean would be
unidentified would be better than
uncertain perhaps
okay no no because you don't need any
identify when you pretty when you put a
numerical value that's why we went back
on that okay I mean but okay let's okay
go back there should be animators or
something yeah go back we're back up to
the anomaly detect stuff so the question
is we've got these things which are
essentially p-values or something
related to P values which determine this
is for shorties benefit which determine
when we would consider the thing to be
an anomaly or in the case of denoising
when we would consider that the thing
was no longer noise
acceptance threshold
that's a nice reusable acceptance I
guess it's better because what we really
the threshold is it's a threshold of
normal ones because we learn the
threshold of normal right
so acceptance threshold would be that
work for both anomaly detection it
seemed so in denying yes
it will work for all of them that's good
it would acceptance threshold yeah it
also makes sense then we can say missing
not accepted yeah why not its general
enough
essentially
look you know what why don't we say
missing below acceptance threshold yeah
yeah you know this is clear except it's
not bellow my b1l yeah it might be
English is freedom
contrary to French we have a Academy the
only problem I have with acceptance
threshold next to recognition threshold
is that it's very difficult to remember
which function takes which one can say
image identify could take an acceptance
threshold and then well um perhaps it
should perhaps we should evolve image
identify to use it very well it could
also be anomaly acceptance which then
along
I think acceptance threshold is a good
name that could be used for everyone
yeah for image identify also okay so we
however however however maybe we will
want to both tell a classifier if it's
below this it's normally but we could
also say if it's below these Dino is it
I don't know if we will put the noise in
some future in predictors
you see what I mean very I know and this
would go back to anomaly threshold and
denoting threshold
well in that case what I would do is say
acceptance threshold no look look look
look look look go back again to
acceptance the middle arrow
it can accept like 12 boots like well
when it doesn't have a why doesn't it
have an association there on the
right-hand side exception threshold
Association
you know anomaly arrow blah-dee you know
denoising arrow blah normally detection
know what it should say is except some
threshold anomaly detection blah
denoising blah right that's the
consistent thing to do
so what that means is it's not sensible
I think what Etienne had was better
noise acceptance threshold rather than
denoising yeah okay fair enough
so it's acceptance threshold for noise
yes
although wait wait wait wait because
it's not acceptance anymore this is you
know the noise is up to like we're
actually accepting it we just I mean
okay maybe it can be a stretch it's just
we don't accept it as easy so we modify
it and this one we don't accept it we
just project it do we really think it's
for real that we'll want to do denoising
as part of classifying
why wouldn't we denoise first it seems
like their different operations relating
to or maybe maybe we are not maybe we
are not giving any control for noise
maybe it's not something that we I don't
think we should I on the face seems to
be it's a different in orthogonal
direction yeah okay so acceptance
threshold then okay so then let's go
down and look at the other thing you
wanted to do which was the the p-value
[Music]
okay okay over here
how do we call it right so so what that
is
well actually we could just call it
p-value there
because
that's a more technical thing at this
point no dicks
threshold as an acceptance threshold for
a p-value well okay
what what is this this is the
probability the estimated probability
that the value exceeds the one given
right that we need to value but
the astronaut more extreme event you
know to find a less likely event so
probably to find the less likely event
and it's not exactly a p-value I guess
so
I mean that seems to be but I mean you
have to do a bit of
translation but the null hypothesis
would be near I know our distribution is
probably forgiven you know that when
Denis is true so when there's no anomaly
area described Amory
bla bla I hate the setup I hate these
days just very I mean it's it's from a
different age all right so let's go back
I'm not a big fan of using if we can
avoid the term p-value I think we should
avoid the term p-value so what actually
is it it is the probability based on our
distribution it's the estimated
let's say that this is exceeded probably
t-to sample less likely
in order to find any near to obtain a
less likely sample
you
if it wasn't a nobody
the ordinary probability to obtain a
less likely sample basically from the
distribution yeah
excluding this particular thing which is
anomalous so it's not part of the
distribution yeah this is tests media
distribution yeah we have a distribution
that's been trained on only nanometers
yeah which by the way is a little bit
different from a p-value but it's a
p-value is you living in the
distribution
No
you know yes I knew typically you have
the distribution of yeah okay okay some
differences yeah okay I mean it's
basically I don't know maybe p-value is
the right term if you're something
better I'm a more free time because I
agreed now I got used to it but yeah we
use it a lot in our discussions yeah so
we value yeah you making sure the people
I know that like lucky spend you know I
had to wrap my brain as well to kind of
see that's right okay let's try again
okay let's try again so what this is is
the probability of all the things that
are less likely than you what is that
aggregate probability it's a cumulative
probability it's CDF actually I mean the
it's a probability yeah yeah it's not
the probability to get this particular
thing it's this snow yeah no yes that is
correct
with we can also return something so one
issue with this p-value business is that
often people will write down things like
that you know like 10 minus 5 you know
which by the way that would be
acceptance threshold 10 to the minus 5
yeah accent unspiritual yes which maybe
is good because it's well explainable in
documentation I think so I don't know if
yeah I don't
don't think it's so good but let me
mention it anyway if we take the log of
the p-value no and when I put negative
sign it can be some sort of anybody
score you know and it can be 1 2 3 and 0
is you know well it would be a normally
exponent or something it will be an
anomaly right we might as well or
something I know acidic is it I mean hey
what's that it's getting what it is
right so log of concentration yeah yeah
I know that's why I said that um okay
and I'm sure the P is something in
German for PID oh one not one is it I
wish but I'm just joking in the okay so
okay
um boy what is the right term for this
the the
it's really the probability of
everything less likely yeah
you
you
I don't know I mean PETA seems I
originally let's say p-value because I
don't anything else
yep it's easy to add synonyms for these
strengths right
no they're wrong yes that's true yeah
it's true okay so now that that's one of
the properties access or properties for
an anomaly - protector but I want to
take this from the top again for a
second okay
anomaly detection I think you okay
anomaly detection takes a bunch of
examples it returns an anomaly detector
function correct yes okay the
alternative which we can have and you
should fill in anomaly detector function
there on the right hand side on just
above way no no no no no no you've got
it there further down three lines
further down yeah I don't have it yeah
the knowledge textual fun right hand
side I see yeah of course yeah okay okay
so this case of anomaly detection of
image giving that is kind of a
degenerate case but it might might as
well work we could also make this won't
work
I think that's more useful the first run
could work by
to see but I don't think it's necessary
okay okay so now we've got acceptance
threshold that's all good
get rid of all the other stuff there yep
okay you comment out all the other stuff
for whatever you want to do put it in
grey or I don't know how you want to do
it or delete it you know what it takes
or whatever else
okay this anomaly frequency is all
irrelevant that's all exceptions that
are showed right no no no this is
different it's different yeah this is
okay let me put p value no no this is so
user I thought I wrote it down exactly
that kind of estimate the rate of
anomaly in the training data yeah oh
these all supposed to be the same thing
with all these different versions of
that yes yes yes yes it was like
brainstorming about what this could be
and so typical use case the user knows
that all the data there's no anomaly in
it so they just say you know I know Mary
X X X goes to zero and we don't even try
to find anomalies in it we just try it
on everything normal distribution and
that's already attacked all which will
be very useful I think to be the main
use actually of this of this option but
instead of doing a true/false type thing
why not making something where we can be
a little bit more you know and say like
the bounds at between you know there's
between 10% and 20% of mine already
okay so while isn't it an estimated
anomaly right estimated anomaly rate
yeah you know yeah
anything with range if you really do you
really typically specify like in that
case you would say 0.15 right the center
of that interval or you could still give
the interval itself I think you just
give the interval I mean possibly as an
interval object but estimate an anomaly
rate you know because often people will
say less than 10% that type of thing
yes which actually like 0.1 or something
yeah exactly
actually that's something we should
think more with Amir is that is the mean
that useful the max is definitely useful
I mean the max is more useful than the
mean but we don't really know how really
important is oh yeah I I think max
anomaly rate is a nice option which says
don't even think about the possibility
that there are more than 10 percent
anomalies
now you know could you ever return an
anomaly rate above 10% if you said max
anomaly rate is 10% or is the algorithm
such that you couldn't do that we like
to make to handle things in a soft way
so I guess I mean actually I mean if we
call it like this probably not so you
would be better two things would be
smooth that we would have a window
around its maximum in general the
algorithms would work better I don't
know how I would ever know I mean I'm
thinking practical cases how would I
ever know it's less than 5% anomalous
it's an estimate I mean you know if it's
zero
you're saying it's useless this animal
in frequency well I the the zero case
isn't useless I mean I think I'm just
trying to think I mean unless you've
tagged the anomalies how would you know
you might know in some weird cases where
there's some regulatory compliance thing
that says there's got to be less than
some number of rat tails in the peanut
butter or something and you're fairly
confident that you satisfied that you
know FDA requirement or something am I
making sense and that therefore you can
assume that these are
alright look I think then if you want it
why not max estimated anomaly right oh
it's a bit uh okay it's a max so you can
pour you you see what I mean
like if you have 20% you put 40% where
that's at the end of the world no I
understand but what if you put 10% and
it's actually 20% and that's the
algorithm insists on you know I don't
think you should have a return an
anomaly rate above yeah I think so too
yeah at least for that data right by the
way
all right so it's either max - normally
rate or max estimated normally rate and
you're arguing for max anomaly rate yes
okay I'm okay with that
and
okay yeah okay okay and if you really
want a min/max
you know you couldn't feed it in as a
two argument thing but I think it's
gonna be a really exotic case okay
schwoeble on detection yeah
anomaly detection what is that anomaly
detect or no you've got tons of stuff on
sale yes yes yes because any don't
showings are more okay okay okay fine
fine fine fine and actually at least one
okay multiple properties decision what
what's decision this will be visa know
many honor this is a classic things you
never specify but it's kind of the same
as this okay just take it from
classifier like if you actually put
decision as a property it will dress
do the normal thing oops look what most
people are going to expect into instead
of that p-value thing is probability
yes yes but again rights it's not this
will be very snotty and all this
probability is not very confusing
yeah it's maybe more confusing than
anything you know
yeah okay fair enough although p-value
actually means probability value which
is the course refusing as hell
which actually present I'll is something
that I think people understand but it's
weird to speak about yeah I mean you
know who could just mix pair about 100
and just say no I don't know
since I rank you know the problems it
what about something that starts with
poverty and it's like something like
well what about cumulative probability
not very convincing no it's not that
it's the probability to exceed in some
sense
yeah so exceeding exceed ability for
access no okay I don't know let's leave
it as p-value for the time being okay
delete anomalies yeah we understand that
one and delete anomalies if you just
give it data okay if you give it a bunch
of images is it going to default to use
to pre-process to flexibly use the image
anomaly detector oh not not exactly no
because there I mean if we follow the
same principle as all these other
function they would learn from the data
and then apply to the data itself we can
have good feature extractors okay so are
we going to say feature extractor error
whatever and is that all we need or do
we need an anomaly detector already you
know about images so if you wanted to do
it on the generic image anomaly detector
you'd say delete anomalies image comma
data is that correct and then it would
use yes the one learnt from that data
but instead - killer exactly actor
exactly okay so the least anomalies
would have its own feature extractor is
that correct actually sorry second
feature extractor yeah I mean in other
words you could give it a pixel cycler
option yes yes yes yes okay and
carefully in this case because you know
some feature extractor actually remove
the noise and remove that normally so
found out that everything is good
because okay so so now then there's
we might think of having an anomaly
detector option instead of this because
this will in the same way with a feature
extractor because this could be used by
classify yeah I think that would be good
Swingle a ceasefire bla bla bla anime a
Tech Talk yeah you know and could be
both a built-in and yes anime take a
function and then we will also have an
acceptance threshold which would
normally be automatic which would
operate with that anomaly detector to
determine whether because without an
anomaly detector classify doesn't really
have an acceptance threshold does it
know unless we by default all classify
train even a simple an exacto which
actually I think we should just in case
you give just totally stupid stuff yeah
yeah it can be a very naive one you know
something that trains super fast let's
compute some stupid statistics about the
input that training set yeah you like if
you give them an identifier a single
pixel
they forget I have no idea what this is
for example it's a Rorschach test for
the computer and actually they think it
the computer thinks it's a picture of a
giant planet eating ostrich you mind I
don't know it could be anything um they
actually this one could also be this I'm
not sure about an ammonia tick-tock
that's okay it can be both of those
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
okay all right down down there and
classify acceptance threshold is simply
automatic and it only becomes active if
there's an anomaly detector correct yes
you know there being an automatic
anomaly detector and only detect our Oh
none has no anomaly detector ignores
acceptance threshold anomaly detector
automatic might do something yes okay
okay
and so we we concluded below acceptance
threshold yeah we concluded it would be
below acceptance threshold and uncertain
will be the other case missing uncertain
actually it really should be
indeterminate and I
that other case will be simply returned
seven it is right or whether we should
have that be returning missing and
determinant yeah if we remove
determinate I would be good to
transforming into missing in the minute
since we only have n-terminal Trish hold
yes so the question is to be removed the
thing that's just indeterminate I mean
the word missing is a little weird me
maybe it should just return
indeterminate in that case and we are
debate about that I mean we obviously
decided to write a vertical bar in the
table yeah we had debate about that
because it's true it's not missing right
so me I was kind of partisan of Chris
keeping hands a minute since we already
added yeah I think there's an argument
for that but then below exception
threshold is more of a missing do we
think
I mean unless we have some symbol that
is uh no I'm gonna go again too hard no
no no no no why do that I mean the
question is is it missing the answer is
yes it's missing because we didn't put
in you know we got pictures of cats and
dogs and actually there's an elephant
there okay yes you're right in a sense
in the first case we cannot figure out
the results so it's missing it's missing
because we don't have the elephant in
the room so to speak it Kennedy's gonna
work yeah because the input was wrong so
we couldn't do we even do anything
no but the example I gave is a
reasonable example we got cats and dogs
we trained on if there was actually you
know okay there's an elephant in the
room
yeah um okay well I think this is not
totally stupid and I think the
indeterminate given that we've already
committed to indeterminate in that other
case I think there's an argument for
just being indeterminate not absolutely
certain of that question that okay let's
keep going on this design please okay
and then there will be the kind of Swiss
Army knife of one shot so it just had to
meaning families you just extract the
anomalies okay you're the same option
that we have to change of course yeah
what was it going right like yeah
anomaly acceptance again later but okay
to be a function where you can you know
ask for the positions I mean this will
be the equivalent of the first one just
returned anomalies
I'll give me the normal in payments both
normal element sounds like some kind of
normal you know so in cells normal form
it can we not come up with a better term
no no those are the elements but the
question is the I mean it would be I
would say anomalous elements instead of
anomalies yeah anomalous elements
non-anomalous elements or something
no no can't lay I'm thinking well maybe
maybe schedule a no maybe can't lay you
know what this isn't right because
positions then we'd have to go to
anomalous positions blah blah blah yes
doctors just elements anomalous that so
then we're back to what you said
positions we can't say anomalies we just
have to say elements find anomalies
elements that's kind of weird of course
that's the equivalent of the of just the
straight one argument form
no the anomalies will be the straight
because it's fine anomalies this will be
the same as a one argument fault of
delete anomalies like I don't think the
eternal values can be made just with how
many knives because it just memories so
it's really about families that can yeah
but so so non-anomalous elements is
delete anomalies so
yes
you
well if you want to do it that way then
it will be just non anomalies anomalies
and non-anomalous no normally is yeah
yeah I like that okay
okay then delete that one and delete
elements down below and then that last
example changes to non anomalies that
okay and yeah this was the competitor
finding anomalies if instead we have an
intact but well look I think did it
follow so so the default wouldn't find
or anything we just do two two two two
two Falls birds we could have second
argument okay this is just detail you
know to ask for the positions and I
think anomaly detect an anomaly
detection of are confusing if we get
point them I mean anomaly detect real by
the way what's that that doing how many
detect and returning true false is not
that useful I wouldn't have thought so
how many anomalies there are actually we
shouldn't under find anomalies we should
probably have a thing called anomaly
count
I normally count as a property right
that boolean could also be associated to
a strain property yes
no just I would say anomaly count where
is a city which the thing that you're
proposing for anomaly detect could be
another property yeah so what would that
be
I mean you should bully a nerd yeah but
but I don't think that's the right time
for it um it's kind of a mask it's kind
of a yes I'm it's the thing the pick
would use it's the um mask oh um let me
see
what is this what is this um
anomaly tests no it's not the tests as
the results of the tests
well how about anomalies vector
it's kind of weird
what is the analogous um encoder the net
encoder that does this true-false
true-false you know net encoder what's
that cold net encoder
yeah no no no go to the net encoder page
yeah okay now open up the net encoders
there's a true/false no that's not the
right thing
lookup net decoder what am I thinking of
here there's a much longer list where is
that there's a much longer list of
encoders and decoders Kalihi tricks
fractals or oh yeah yeah that's right
they killed
you
okay don't we have a thing like this the
indicator vector
No
I mean it obscurely it will be called an
indicator vector of some kind yes
something that returns what is yeah when
you do list which is a clustering
function that returns
whether something's in a cluster or not
trust ring components yeah that's right
that does return those kinds of things
it's it's numbered its label matrices
it's come back or label erase integer
index index it's kind of anomaly in
let's say boolean masks for now it's at
a boolean vector let's say a boolean
less boolean list boolean list is better
than boolean mask sounds less mysterious
so to speak
let's go do that for now that's all
right
in case I don't think that's the most
used okay this next thing is deleted yep
okay so here we actually decided but no
we decided on that okay missing
irritation and missing imputation okay
by the way since that is here for 12
will only deal with numerical and
nominal data and the reason is it's the
only you know place I mean well hold on
a second
there's no reason why we can't have like
a chroma key thing in an image so to
speak saying this pixel value is what we
consider missing to be
similarly in a string we could perfectly
well say you know this beauty code this
character is what we consider missing to
be a star represents missing for example
mm-hmm
I don't see any reason to I don't see
any problem with that I think that's
gonna be a convenient thing to do anyway
even if we have some more general
representation of missingness yeah so
okay so what I would suggest that in
terms of missing imputation is that it
would be something like an image arrow
what be what the thing assumed to be
missing is so you mean image blah blah
blah arrow in the image in the first
argument of missing imputation oh I see
I see
so okay so let's go to missing
imputation and that I'm missing in
pewter function function or is it just
missing yeah no it's nothing a Beautif
um ssin yeah and and you say we could
have something and then we have its bit
it's gonna be yeah interesting how to
well okay this is write that down for
now that's like the chroma key you know
that's like the thing that represents
well let's say missing token is what it
is it's the token that represents the
missing things oh I see I see okay so
for example a green screen right would
be like missingness or a star analyst
might be like missingness oh that would
solve a lot of problem indeed right I
mean we have to do yeah to do some good
surgery on the image because if you
start transforming it and it's over okay
but so so I'm not sure that's the right
notation for this I mean the alternative
would be the thing you know an option
which exactly yeah I was actually
thinking about using comma and then
missing talking yeah so missing let's
say missing token but I'm not sure
that's the right
yeah and by default it's going to be
missing what about calling it missing
data token missing data
yeah for missing data token and then
well by default it might be underscore
missing and by default yeah sure sure
yeah that's kind of what before is and
do you want to say that first case
missing tokens on the right thing we're
missing data token yeah I would think
probably okay you just said the exact
same thing in each case there yeah no no
no no you want missing data token no I
know I know but that's okay it's off the
table the missing token is completely
off the table missing they don't we'll
wait that seems like something missing
behavior I mean yes you do stop missing
yeah exactly missing missing behavior
put this method sorry before as well
yeah yeah contains recently so it's
lookups no missing behavior is something
different that's what to do if you see a
missing thing this is a new idea yeah
missing that I miss it again that's
that's similar missing data
what missing behavior what the heck is
missing behavior as opposed to missing
data method temporal data another
function yeah that's okay so look up
missing behavior
he's an option to query and related
philosophy
these reinterpreting the business of
Italia ISM how did you call the cowboy
or design yes what design cover I'm not
really thrilled about this thing this
missing behavior thing
but no case it's not relevant to this
this is mum missing data token I think
is probably the most reasonable term for
it
it's fairly clear what it means the only
thing is that for images you won't you
won't be saying RGB color 1 0 0 you want
a range of some sort so it's not really
a token it's a range of values perhaps
as well for data right
possibly I mean why would it be arranged
like in that chroma key example Stephen
is given you wouldn't want to give a
range you would give a specific value
map a range of values on to one specific
chroma key value that's a more stable
and unsecure thing to do I think I guess
it would be two step first whatever you
think is me seeing you paint it right
and then I mean look you you can do
something I'm not sure you'd specify a
range of colors I mean it's a you know
do we we don't really have a way to say
this region of the chromaticity diagram
we're proposing a collar neighborhood
object which is which is just a wrapper
that specifies with what color distance
around what color with one I kiss your
shape here that then missing data token
could be color neighborhood at blah blah
blah okay but I'm wondering if the token
is still the right name for the option
this is like a bit of a court I mean
extreme case which the color case yeah I
mean general would just say in this
expression and it's for you to do the
proposal thing and see the problem is I
I like the term well okay to write down
another possibility missing data
indicator they might be better than
token might be less technical one token
by the way
would be a sort of wrapper around the
nature around the data yeah select yeah
missing data and data and indicate oh I
don't think that's necessary and I think
we would expect then a lot of other
functions to work on that yeah
you
I think we just leave that in there
leave that leave that Emma as a note
okay
rabbie idea yeah okay
okay then we have methods great Oh
most likely hey that's up unnamed option
and I'm the option to say so
basically missing imputation will again
learn the distribution of the data then
you cannot have to choice when possibly
more I guess but could define a family
oh this is Callum wound up being in the
method option this whole thing about
what you fill at him with sad that's
kind of what I was thinking
cuz I think you most you know most of
the time what you fill it in with is the
most likely thing to be there that's
what you want to disagree with that
Eddie's agree with that really is a very
dangerous thing yes because you know
let's say you in numerical space and the
most likely you have a little Dirac and
but then you have a big you know a big
Montaigne somewhere else
I see it's most likely context right the
most likely thing to be there look I
mean if you're if you've got a scratch
on a photograph and it's a scratch in
front of a you know a piece of grass or
something it's most likely to be green
with the scratch in front of a sample
the sample will will okay what I mean by
most likely like the mode I mean even if
it's sample it will always put a piece
of grass also
practical point of view is going to be
better for us to return sample than to
try to optimize and flock it so the
argument world if you've got a scratch
across the piece of grass plus the area
of grass in the most likely mode model
probably that whole scratch is filled
with the same color
yeah and in the likely so this would be
the likely and most likely in a way but
because in the in in the sample case
will work as well
I think we need to see some examples I
it should be initially in the method
option and maybe it gets promoted okay
issue with metal option is we also want
to specify the distribution method so
that would mean you know we did that for
active classification where you want to
but what should be the default when you
just say method method to what when
you're just sorry method without an
association I don't know I don't care we
don't have doesn't have to work I talk
to you I mean we could have a few string
names whether where they work and they
Bank switches and things or we could
just not have it where I think by
default it should be the distribution
method and I don't know fine here let's
just keep going I have a moment so okay
so then you use a missing in pewter
function okay right there's not much and
you have a same up for any year that you
can change oh that's yeah okay that we
measure them and missing include to be
the one-shot get data imported data
simple where we met when when whenever I
buy buy buy wait why isn't
that
you
you
hmm okay all right I guess that's right
and Oh actually I was going back to the
representation of missing data but we
already discussed that okay that's all
for missing imputation
okay let's quickly discuss data generate
whatever that is
later synthesized yeah so learn from the
data and then resample from the learned
distribution
and yeah and since it knows it's just
about generation and it will pick
distributions that good at generating
and we care as if they can compute the
PDF or impute missing values or denies
whatever and so yeah that I don't like
the name I mean first of all it should
be synthesizing not generator generators
just way too general and whatever I mean
yeah I mean yeah we like it he suggested
this but it doesn't get across the idea
that it's from learned
it's like if you're writing a biomedical
paper and you just want to fake all your
data use this function
why on earth is it giving a dataset
what doesn't just generate the damn data
okay so in that case
yeah that's what it should do in my view
yes just retire just like yeah I mean
listen listen maybe there's a different
version of this maybe it should be you
know what it should have the word random
in it
random by 800 random data that's what it
kind of is
you know we've got random word we've got
random color we've got randomness we've
got random random synthesized data
try try that destroy down random
synthesized data
emphasize that data
that's what this really is I mean this
is a very bizarre operation
to be honest this is a very very very
bizarre operation actually random
synthesized
would be a good name
because what it's going to do if you say
synthesized of data a comma five it's
going to generate five randomly
synthesized things that are sort of
related to that data mm-hmm
I mean random synthesizers image comma
five what the heck is it gonna give you
pictures of cats I mean if you just put
them image you can say there's not
enough data no no no no I know but if
you say quotes image oh okay
quote gonna give you probably pictures
of cats yes I mean it's just a very
weird thing
I mean random synthesize of word for
example right would probably give you
synthesized English words which will be
cool
right random but I think random
synthesizes the right name I think it's
a mere name for this name and you can
have we kind a favor can go crazy there
yeah right I think this is a totally
weird function right it's a very amusing
demo function it'll be useful for
generating examples the case where you
give it real chunks of data will be
quite useful
yes exactly when you give real I mean
yeah
I like this and I like the name but I
never size the right name because
there's a lot of randomness in it you
don't want it's gonna be different every
time unless you randomly seed it the
same and so on and run synthesizer what
I'm since I performed are we doing that
no there's no oh yes we need we need to
have something that you can set aside on
demand like you don't want to retrain
each time it may be something you need
to synthesize a function maybe don't
call it random synthesizer so that's
still the first one art form gives you
one sample back so random synthesizer
gives you the random synthesizer
function that's pretty weird because
random word just gives you around no no
no don't do that no but I'm saying but
what it n is written they're random
synthesized of data gives you the
function back yeah but most probably
most one at case is random synthesized
data gives you one sample back I would
think so yeah that's just one example
yes oh well the other possibility I mean
I have to say I would be much functional
property stuff that would kind of
compete with a number possible but I
think you should write the first one
random synthesized from data a single
example there just as a single example
there now you know look in a perfect
world we would just use some kind of
weak hashing thing to simply store if
you give the exact same data again you
want to export this you want to put that
on the cloud you want to
like I'm a function thing I don't think
that's gonna work but it's it's very
important to have it no no I understand
that I understand I don't think it's
gonna work with the comma function thing
it's not gonna work
right it's some why not because we've
used it differently in a million
different ways all we go back to the
standardization and these returns that
is not an English word
there will be synthesis why not Santa
sizer synthesizer random synthesizer
well you proposing that random
synthesizer function isn't
or can just return the random
synthesizer object if you don't want
three of them oh wait wait wait what are
you proposing here random synthesized so
random synthesized is settled random
synthesizer can return a random
synthesizer object or a random
synthesizer function object either one
of those
you
we have objects that are both
constructor and the object itself like I
understand where he's proposing that
random synthesizer returns just sits
there as a random synthesizer which can
be fed in as the first argument to
random synthesize probably okay I mean
it could also be fed in as an argument
to random variate but this is going away
from the design of the other
Imagineering functions and especially
the supervised learning follow all this
procedure like the verb he's doing it
directly and whatever else is producing
the functions that would make sense we
just decided actually we added in two
functions before but then we decided to
kind of merge them we could realize now
let's consider this and okay let's try
it I mean this function may be so
Bunker's that we feel differently about
it yeah I mean it may be you know we may
run down the stupid pun we make get
catty about it never mind okay so this
would be the oh yes and then the
synthesizer would be used kind of
I guess yeah the the of no arguments is
a habit is equivalent to one
sorry know that the of no arguments form
yeah no not equivalent because the one
would have oh yeah lowest price okay I
agree by the way random variate of a
random short synthesizer function should
present all work
okay I should probably go because
supposed to do some other meeting here
yeah if you wait till next week I mean
this is great okay how long until we can
get all this stuff sort of in the system
don't look too difficult it looks
largely cosmetic what we've talked about
here yeah yeah I mean I mean the big
thing is the distribution right which is
on its way I mean we'll ask something no
matter what now we're going to try to
push it so it's as finished as possible
for good I mean yeah I want to see what
random sample size doesn't matter it's
all caps and there'll be a separate
project to to train this built-in basic
good synthesizers for images especially
it needs a lot of training for each
special cases well I don't know the
special guy mean look just saying a
random image is a pretty weird thing
honestly I think you know more you know
it's like almost like give me a random
Flickr photograph or something
[Music]
okay all right well looks great all
right I think that's it and let's wrap
it up
thanks to folks on the livestream and
see you later